there are three types of sales people
out there that don't get the kind of
results they want it sells let's talk
about the first kind the / sellers these
are people that are willing to say
anything misrepresent they're willing to
over-promised under-deliver bash the
competitors spread rumors about the
competitor just to get you to buy their
product these are the over sellers the
second kind or those that are the under
sellers these are folks that are afraid
to offend you what if they rub you the
wrong way but if you don't like the
question to ask what if you would if you
push them a little bit and you ask the
tough questions they're afraid to do
that little bit timid little bit shy and
the last one is those that don't sell
they just present they tell you what the
product is great.i giving you the facts
giving you the features giving you the
benefits but they don't ask the
questions that they need to ask so
they're not prepared they're just
presenters so the over seller the under
seller the presenter let me give it a
challenge and a benefit of each one the
over sellers what they have going for
themselves is they have audacity they're
not afraid they're willing to say
whatever they can the challenge with
them is they typically had a bad example
of somebody they shadowed that did all
the bad things salespeople do and they
duplicated that habit or they have an
understanding of what you're supposed to
do in sales like say anything to make
the sale and that's how they view sales
those two things can hurt them if those
two things can come back and built under
solid foundation of values principles
that work in the world of sales they can
have a long-term career if not you'll be
out of sales in no time the under
sellers are typically shy or they don't
believe in their product you know
they're you're they're timid they're shy
and if there's one thing I can say one
of the most expensive habits you could
have is to be shy one of the most
expensive traits in the world is to be
shy if you are afraid to ask the
question look some of the best people I
buy products from are naturally shy but
I buy it from them because I trust them
okay let me explain Zuckerberg is
naturally an introvert Bezos Gates
they're all introverts right but they
had to sell to investors that to sell
the software the website the product the
philosophy they have to sell the idea
that Amazon's gonna put eventually
borders and Barnes ennoble out of
business they had to figure out a way to
do it so shy people if you're shy
someone kind of timid I don't believe in
a product good
whatever you can to study the products
your conviction is 100% so you know you
can sit up talk to anybody and your eyes
gonna look at it would I be nervous
about it or start asking tougher
questions and stop being so nervous
about worried about rubbing people the
wrong way you got to get the shyness out
of you or at least use it as an
advantage last viñales knows that don't
ask and they just present this doesn't
mean you're a bad sales percentage just
means you don't have us to write
questions you got to get the top 20 fa
Q's in your industry frequently asked
questions and you got to go to your
closers and your company in your
industry and find out what are the best
transitional questions they ask on a
call when they prosper when they sell
closing questions and then start
applying them to your presentations your
results will be night and day income
doesn't go up 50% when you start asking
questions instead of presenting your
income goes up like six seven eight
hundred percent if not a thousand
percent because if you're making five
grand now all of a sudden you gonna make
fifty thousand dollars that's not 100
percent growth that's a lot of growth
because you're starting to learn to ask
the right questions and overcome
objections having said that look
challenge to you here's a challenge to
all of you if it's 2020 and you still
haven't made a decision to learn how to
sell and negotiate the 2020s are gonna
be roaring for a lot of people it ain't
gonna be roaring for you because if
there is a skill that's a mandatory in
2020 to help create wealth and attract
wealth for you moving forward is sales a
negotiation a lot of people tell me Pat
a what books should I read what courses
should I take here's what I tell them
take them all make sure whoever wrote
the book didn't write the book because
they make money selling books they did
something in a different industry for 5
10 15 20 years then made them millions
that they're willing to share it with
you ok so the course is online if
somebody made a lot of money running a
business they were selling a negotiating
go take it if an FBI agent was a former
hostage negotiator and he's not selling
of course on master class go buy the
course unlearn it but learning from
those folks average sales course myself
that we just launched I'm sharing my
sales system that I share with my 13,000
agents you want to know about it we'll
put the link below
learn those things for yourself and if
you're somebody right now that you want
to improve your sales system and sales
process watch this video here so video
you can go watch on YouTube I break down
exactly certain areas in the sales flow
that a lot of people have leaks in and
it costs them a lot of money and this
will hopefully identify some of the
leaks for you that can help you make a
lot more money
having said that have a killer week
everybody take care love you
bye bye
[Music]